try and interpret this line Charlie is
twice as old as Dave this means that
Charlie's age is twice that of Dave's
let's try to write this in a shorter way
assume Charlie's age is C and that of
Dave's is D when we try to write phrases
as equations remember that the word is
always means equal to so we write an
equal to after see twice Dave's H can be
written as 2 D so C is equal to 2 D is a
shorter way to write this line here's
the second layer armor pot 5 pens more
than the number of pens been bought we
can assume the number of pens Armour
bought to be a the number of pens been
bought to be B armor BOTS can be written
as a equals 5 pens more than some number
so we leave some space and write plus 5
5 more than bit 5 more than the number
of pens been bought which is B so a
equals B plus 5 explains this line in a
shorter way easy you think now look at
this line Zara salt thrice as many pins
as calculators pause the video and try
to write the equation with P and C as
variables
breaking the line down we can write
thrice as many pens as 3p as many as
calculators can be written as equal to C
twice as many pens as calculators right
sorry that's incorrect let's take an
example say the number of calculators
she sold is 10 so C will be 10 units
she sold thrice as many pens as the
number of calculators she sold so P will
be 30 plus 3 times 30 equal 10 No
so P is equal to 3 C is the correct way
to write it if C is 10 then P will be
equal to 3 times 10 30 units 3 C tells
us thrice as many as calculators now we
can move on to an actual example the
length of a rectangle is 2 more than its
breadth find its length and breadth if
its perimeter is 16 units let's name the
length as L and the breadth as B the
length is 2 more than its breadth this
was the most important relationship in
this problem the length of the rectangle
is 2 more than its breadth we don't
really need two variables here let's say
the breadth is equal to X units putting
X in place of B here gives us L as X
plus 2 now that we have established a
relation between the length and breadth
let's move on to the second point the
perimeter is given to us as 16 units so
twice L plus B will equal 16 units yes
the perimeter is 2 times the length plus
2 times the breadth as L is X plus 2 and
B is X we get this equation solving this
we get the value of x as 3 units don't
forget you are not asked to find the
value of x you are asked to find the
length and the breadth as B
is X it will measure three units and as
the length is two more than its breadth
it will measure five units always verify
your answer length is two more than its
breadth that's correct
and two times three plus five does give
us sixteen so we can be certain that
possess correct
you